learn how to succeed as an engineering
manager in this course from an Kar
anyone can learn to be a good leader
Hita is an experienced engineering
manager and she has a bunch of great
tips to share with you a lot of
developers aren't sure how to become a
engineering leader or to succeed as an
engineering manager or a leader they
continue to act like individual
contributors as they aren't sure how to
manage and as a result the people that
report into them or under the leadership
suffer now just like we learned
JavaScript angular react or any other
upcoming technology just like that
leadership is also a skill set that you
need to develop and learn no one is a
born leader you need to learn how to
become a good leader in this specific
course I wanted to cover a few things
and give you a plan and strategy to
become a successful engineering leader
so we will cover things like what I wish
I knew before becoming an engineering
manager how to become a great leader a
engineering leadership road map what are
some differences between a software
engineering manager and a technical lead
and not just that we will also cover how
to communicate as a developer which will
also translate into leadership skills
and how to give and receive feedback as
a developer and a leader so I really
hope you enjoy this course if you have
any questions just comment below and let
me know are you a individual contributor
that is curious about engineering
leadership or you want to know what it
takes to become a successful engineering
manager
as I reflected back in my career there
were a few things that I kind of wish I
knew before I made the transition to
becoming an engineering manager so in
this video I'm going to cover it all so
first of all I want to say that I was
quite happy with the move but I really
want you to know all these things so you
can make the best decision for yourself
so let's get started so the first thing
that I experience as a transition from
being a developer to an engineering
manager was that you do feel like an
outsider to your very own team now you
have a lot more power right being a
leader you can basically decide who get
you get to hire within the team who gets
promoted you know all the salaries of
your team members so you're not going to
look at your team the same way as you
did before so you start feeling like an
outsider to your very own team that is
the first thing you will experience as
you make the transition or at least I
did because you have a lot more control
and power you are now in charge of
making the decisions your team is going
to look up to you as a leader if they
don't know what to do they are going to
look up to you for that so that is a bit
of a shift and a mindset shift that you
need to go through as you make the
transition so the percentage of time
that you will spend coding will
drastically and significantly reduced as
a engineering manager a lot of people
have this misconception that as you
transition from being a developer to an
engineering manager it is basically a
promotion it is the same role maybe with
a little bit more of people management
respons responsibilities well if you
want to be a mediocre engineering
manager then sure you can do that but
don't spend a lot of time cing because
again you have a lot more responsibility
as an engineering manager your first
goal should be to grow the people on
your team make sure that they are set up
for success make sure you are reviewing
their performance giving constructive
feedback managing stakeholders doing
road map planning for the future and
there is lots more that you need to do
to make sure that you are setting up
your team for success as an engineering
leader they are looking up to you for
leadership so if you spend a lot of time
coding behind the computer then you
necessarily will not have time to focus
on your other important responsibilities
and this will not make you a successful
engineering manager so you might be
wondering well if I'm not going to code
then how am I called an engineering
manager will I not just be a manager
then well here's the thing you still
have a lot of technical expertise that
got you to to where you were right but
when you take on an engineering manager
position it's a completely different
role you can still use your strengths
from being a developer and you should
definitely be involved in knowing all
the architectural decision making sure
that your team has really good standards
technically make sure there are good
code review processes make sure that you
understand the all the architectural
decisions being made and your team is
not just thinking just for that specific
mod module that you're working on but
they're also thinking about the
scalability as well right so your
experience as a developer is going to
definitely help you when you transition
to become an engineering manager but
again what got you here will not
necessarily get you to where you want to
go being a successful engineering
manager so make sure that you keep this
in mind as you transition so again
should you code well it totally depends
on your team's responsibil ilities if
you have everything else under control
if you do want to pick up a task here
and there just to make sure you
understand the code base a little bit
more you are able to give feedback to
your team and you're not just a manager
managing you also are involved and they
feel that you are involved as well then
you can definitely do that but again
make sure that the main focus of your
position of your role is not to code
it's all these other things including me
maybe a little bit of coding so again
make sure you don't spend a lot of time
doing that you will feel a therapist
many times as you deal with people so
people are the people on your team are
going to come to you with all sorts of
problems the performance is not
necessarily tied to their day-to-day job
but also what's going on personally
what's going on outside of work as well
so sometimes you might feel like you
know a lot more about them personally as
well in order to make sure you connect
with them professionally and you don't
necessarily need to do that but I guess
being a good engineering manager you
need to care about the people that you
work for well you will feel like a
therapist at times because you will
spend a lot of time talking about their
thoughts and feelings but it's also
important that you start drawing
boundaries because you know people are
going through maybe a lot of stuff so if
they need to talk to someone
professional other than you then
definitely advise them of that as well
but you will feel at times that it's
necessary to talk to them not just about
work stuff but also about personal stuff
so make sure that you keep it all
confidential because they think of you
as a leader and they trust you and
that's why they're sharing all this
information with you so make sure that
you do that for an example there was a
developer who I was managing and they
clearly were not giving their 100% And I
personally felt I could see that they
were not even though they were always on
top of their performance
in this specific case they were not
necessarily doing that their performance
was not great anymore so I got really
curious to just check in and ask them
what's impacting them and it turns out
there was something personal going on
without getting into too many details I
was able to navigate and guide them in
terms of how they can manage their
personal and professional life and I
also asked them to maybe take a day off
a personal day just to make sure that
they take care of that before they can
focus on work the next day they came
back and they were able to really
recharge and really take the time off
and deal with whatever they had to deal
with personally to be able to show up at
work and give their 100% so again this
is important that you have that empathy
and that and you treat people as humans
and not just resources when you are an
engineering manager being an engineering
manager can be lonely at times like I
mentioned that you will feel not feel
like the same team member and anymore as
you did before when you are an IC and as
you become an engineering manager you
cannot necessarily talk to the
developers on your team about the
problems that are going on in the
company because as a leader you need to
Shield them from that you need to make
sure that they feel comfortable talking
to you about things and they feel like
their position is in a good spot if you
talk to them only about the problems
that are there or what whatever is going
on in your mind then they might not feel
as confident about the team and the
company that they work at so make sure
that you Shield them of that but also
find a support system for yourself and
other engineering leaders that you can
talk to about problems as well so maybe
find a mentor take care of your own
mental health and make sure that you
have a good support system so that you
can talk about problems or and come up
with Solutions as well your direct
reports are also going to share
something personal and private with you
and you will will not be able to share
that with anyone else and you need to
keep it confidential right because this
there is that is their personal
information there's a lot that you will
keep to yourself and which will also
make engineering leadership a little bit
lonely but it doesn't have to be you can
find your support system you can join a
community you can talk to other people
and their leaders going through the same
Journey as you so that you don't feel
alone because it can definitely feel
lonely at times I was also socially
exhausted being in a lot of meetings I
as I transition from being a developer
to a manager now I was booked in a lot
of backtack meetings because everyone
wanted to get a piece of me everyone had
to pick my brain on things and I had to
make a lot of decisions just to make
sure that my team is on the right path
but it doesn't have to be you don't have
to be socially exhausted so you need to
start planning your week a little bit
better trying to figure out what the
focus of the the week is what your
priorities are of that week and
accordingly push the things that are not
that important to the next week and try
to say no as well which we will cover
later in this specific video but you
will be socially exhausted as you will
be in a lot more meetings than you did
being a developer as an engineering
manager you will shield the team from
unnecessary meetings but that also means
you are going to accept a lot more
meetings because you want to make sure
that you have things under control so
you will be socially exhausted make sure
that you spend some time take some time
in the morning or in the afternoon and
book some Focus time for yourself in
your calendar then no one gets to book
over so that we can get some me time and
are also able to get some work done as
well but that is a reality you will feel
socially exhausted at first without
proper systems in place you are going to
find a bit difficult to say no at first
now unless you were a leader before and
you are already good at that then please
ignore this but if you're not then it is
definitely going to be a bit difficult
for you to say no know because everyone
would need a piece of your team they
would all come to you for priorities
their priorities that they need to work
on and you need to figure out how you
can position those priorities along with
current priorities that your team is
working on if you say yes a lot your
team is going to be burnt out so make
sure that you don't say yes to everyone
a strategy that I transitioned was
instead of saying no you can talk to
them about the priorities that you do
have and accordingly prioritize their
stuff maybe in the next quarter or maybe
a month from now and so on so you're not
necessarily saying no you are saying not
now let's do this at this specific date
so again but you're going to have it a
bit of a difficult time initially to say
no and make sure that you know what your
priorities are as you transition to
being a manager you are going to manage
a team that will have different
personalities so for example some might
be more extroverted and will speak up a
lot more While others are not as
extroverted and they don't speak up and
maybe need an opportunity to do so so
for example extroverted folks are going
to talk as they think and they will keep
talking whereas introverted folks will
need some time to think first and then
talk about anything so you really need
to make sure that you're balancing both
personality types in a specific team so
that you're not just listening to one
specific personal type as you make
decisions you need to balance it out to
make sure that you are asking questions
and making sure that you're including
everyone in the meeting making sure that
you have organized the meeting in such a
way that everyone can speak up and give
their thoughts maybe you can ask someone
about what they are thinking and so on
but again you are going to deal with a
lot of different personality types so
you need to make sure you need to
balance them all otherwise you're only
going to lean on to the the person that
is the loudest and you really don't want
to do that as an engineering manager you
want to create a transparent culture and
people where people are happier to work
for you they are excited in the morning
to come work for you for the team and
you are going to be a huge part of that
that's why it's important for you to
make sure that you take this into
account what got you here will not
necessarily get you further as a
developer it's your job to make sure
that your skills are up to date right so
if there's a specific technology that
you work in a in your team for example
react how do you make sure that the
performance of the app is really good or
how do things work with server
components and so on right now react is
important as a developer because that's
a technology that your team is using but
when you transition to being a manager
you shouldn't be focusing on making sure
that you have up-to-date react skills
you need to be focused on how can you be
be the best manager that you can be and
those skills are very different than
being a developer skills so make sure
you're spending time on the development
of your skills as well such as how do
you give constructive feedback how do
you promote someone how do you do
performance reviews and so on sometimes
you are going to disappoint people
because they are not because their
promotion did not get accepted and even
though you think that they deserve to
get promoted you need to be in a
position to put them forward in the best
possible way and those are skills that
you need to learn which you didn't
necessarily knew about when you were a
developer so again there are a lot more
skills that you need to learn being an
engineering manager that you won't
necessarily know as a developer so make
sure you keep learning and figure out
how others are doing it in the company
Are there specific strategies and
Frameworks that you can use to make sure
that you're giving feedback the right
way or if someone is causing any
troubles in the team then make sure then
are aware of that without making them
feel too bad about it there so many
things that you will deal with as an
engineering manager that you didn't
necessarily deal with before so make
sure that you are on top of your
personal skills as well and your reading
books ebooks and so on just to make sure
that you have control of everything and
again it this makes the journey fun for
you as well because you're not just
stuck with the skills that you
transitioned with you also are always
improving and growing and experimenting
with the team that you're working with
so that your team becomes a really high
performing team unfortunately not every
day is going to be a good day being a
manager sometimes you have to give
really difficult feedback to your team
or specific team member and their
response to that might be really
emotional because feedback is really
difficult and because of that your day
is going to be impacted you are going to
spend hours talking to someone just to
make sure that they understand the
impact they're possibly having on the
team and again that can be very
exhausting sometimes you want to get
someone promoted but their promotion is
not going to get accepted or they want
more salary and you are unable to get it
approved for whatever reason you are
going to have a bad day because of that
because it is going to be really
emotional for you so being an
engineering manager can be very
difficult because you are dealing with
people and people are humans not just
computers when you are a developer
you're writing code and you're just
dealing with computers you're obviously
dealing with Team Dynamics and
communication and whatnot but being a
manager that is in the Forefront that's
why you really need to make sure that
you're taking care of your mental health
as you transition because it's not just
your team's mental health that's
important it's also yours because if
yours will start to get affected then
the team is going to experience the same
as well it's the same analogy that when
you're in an airplane make sure that
you're you're wearing an oxygen mask as
well before you give it to other people
it's the same thing being a manager that
you are always in service of other
people but make sure that you also take
care of your mental health and your
personal needs as well and if you do
need to take the time off then please do
so because that will have an impact on
others too so again make sure you take
care of yourself what if you don't like
being an engineering manager and you
want to go back to being a developer you
really like coding and now you have to
deal with all these different things
that you don't necessarily want to deal
with or you had a misunderstanding of
the position and I want to say that if
you do give it a shot let's say there's
an opportunity available in your team or
in a company and you decided to go for
it and 6 months later or a year later
you are like you know what I Lov being a
manager but I love being a developer as
well so I want to go back it's
completely okay for you to go back in
fact I would highly recommend it it's
it's important to keep going back and
forth between being a manager and being
a developer so that you are really
appreciative of both positions because a
lot of times when you're a developer you
don't necessarily know what a
engineering manager has to go through
because they don't necessarily will
share everything with the team because
they're supposed to Shield the team
right so being a manager and then
switching to a developer you are going
to build a lot more empathy as well but
there's nothing wrong in switching back
and forth it in fact it's totally
recommended because if you think about
it in your career throughout your life
if you want to stick to just being one
position and it's probably not going to
be as challenging but by switching back
and forth you're learning a lot more
skills that will be helpful in either
way so again if you really want to
switch go for it but I would highly
recommend you to also give it a shot to
see if you really like being an
engineering manager and making sure that
your skills are up to date and you are
always learning and growing because as a
developer you do that so do the same
when you transition to being a manager
well I talked a lot about what it was
like when I transitioned from being a
developer to an engineering manager I
know you might be wondering is it even
worth it to become an engineering
manager well I would say yes it's really
rewarding seeing the growth of people
and the impact that you are going to
have on folks I have worked with so many
different people and when I do give them
feedback or I provide suggestions and
insights based on my experience to help
them grow it is awesome to see that they
work on those and they grow because of
you as well so the impact is going to be
huge on other people's career so again
being an engineering manager is really
rewarding the other thing is you will
have a lot more influence and your
impact is really going to grow massively
in a company because your focus is not
just going to be your team but your
impact is going to be really visible
across the org as well right so being a
developer you only think about your team
but being an engineering manager your
influence and your impact is going to
grow a lot more which won't necessarily
be possible being a developer by being
an engineering manager you get to
control or have a say on the road map on
what your team gets to work on So based
on the goals of the company you get to
decide what's important for the team the
problems that you will solve as an
engineering manager will be at a larger
scale and it won't be at a smaller scale
anymore so again you are going to be
solving bigger problems that are
important for the company for for not
just your one team but several teams so
your impact is going to be a lot more if
you take advantage of it being a manager
if teams are not working together you
get to be the one to make sure that they
talk to each other they have the same
common understanding you become the
decision maker but also someone who
comes and resolves problems and it
sometimes is going to be hard because
misunderstandings can happen but as an
engineering manager you are the leader
so they are going to look up to you for
solving all their problems and even
though you don't necessarily need to
solve the problem on your own you can
make sure that the teams get together
and talk it out and facilitate the
meeting so that problems get resolved so
the problems that you'll be solving
won't just be your own problem as you
were when you were a developer but you
get to control and and you get to work
on a lot more problems because of it so
I would say that being an engineering
manager is really rewarding if there is
an opportunity in your organization or
your team where you get to be a leader I
would highly recommend you to take up
that position and learn the skills
necessary to become a engineering
manager now having said that I hope this
video was really useful for you I really
wanted to make sure that I cover all my
feelings that I went through from being
a i to a manager
and before you take up the position I
want you to know what you need to be
aware of as you go through so you don't
feel alone software career paths career
ladders you name it there are so many
different names for the same thing it is
extremely important as a developer to
know what career path is right for you
and what are the different levels you
can go to as you grow in your career
there are different titles in the
industry and every title is so confusing
that it's hard to know whether you
should become an engineer manager or a
staff developer or a technical lead so
we will be talking about titles and how
they can be so confusing and what are
some things that you should be aware of
in Tech so as a developer there are
typically two career paths that you can
take and there are different levels in
different companies now there is a
diagram in right in front of us and I'm
just you showing you this diagram just
to give you an understanding of the
different levels and what these fancy
titles are like so you get a really good
understanding of what every level is
expected to do and what to know about it
so for example if you are a developer
there are two paths one is called the
individual contributor path and the
other one is the leadership track now a
lot of times you will find that an IC
path has not that many levels compared
to an leadership path and that is why a
lot of developers end up becoming
managers because they don't know how
else to grow unless they go into a
leadership track but it doesn't
necessarily have to you need to find the
right company and the team where these
levels are properly defined so you can
keep growing even after you reach a
specific level so for example as a
developer you can first become a
entry-level developer then you join to
intermediate developer and then you go
to a senior developer but whereas if you
are already a senior developer or even a
high intermediate you can become a
technical lead a staff Dev or a
engineering manager I have some good
news I have been working on a course to
take you from a developer to a
engineering manager and make you a very
successful engineering manager so if
you're interested add yourself to the
weight list this course will cover
everything that we have talked about in
this specific engineering manager series
but there's a lot more that I couldn't
cover in this series that I will cover
in the course so please feel free to
check it out and take a look in the
description below now it's a very common
thing that there would be three
different levels in a developer titles
for example there would be an
entry-level developer an intermediate
developer and a senior developer and a
senior is supposed to take on a lot more
leadership responsibilities and tasks
compared to a intermediate or an
entry-level developer and a senior
developer is also maybe asked to Mentor
maybe more - level devs or maybe devs
more Junior to them just so that they
start practicing their leadership
responsibilities as well so being senior
doesn't just mean that you write code
but you also need to make sure that
you're mentoring others and helping
improve your processes your team
processes and so on as well but the
minute you become a senior developer it
does open up two paths for you one is
that you can become a technical lead a
staff developer after that you can
become a solution architect now again it
completely depends in every company that
that after a senior developer you can
become an architect and what is the
difference between an architect and a
staff developer or a tech lead well an
architect is mainly responsible for
architecting the different apps they are
responsible for maybe growing the team
an architect really takes a look at the
company's architecture holistically and
recommends the best practices and make
sure that the architecture makes sense
and you might have heard the joke that
an architect does draw a lot of boxes
which is which is not wrong but an
architect does a lot more and they think
about the company holistically the
company architecture holistically
technically then a CA developer could
also become a technical lead or a staff
Dev and a tech lead would essentially be
more responsible for leading all the
technical
responsibilities uh of a developer for
example but depending on the company
after a tech lead you can become a
principal developer
or a distinguished engineer or a fellow
now again these are different levels and
the responsibilities keep growing but
again and and the scale at which you do
these things are also different so for
example a distinguished engineer or a
principal developer or a fellow role may
not be available in more smaller or
medium-sized companies because there's
not a need for it but in bigger
companies such as the Fortune 500
companies you will more likely see the
these roles just so that people when
they reach a specific level they're
still able to grow and they have
something to strive for and they don't
just leave the company so as a developer
you can take the IC path and this is
what your path will look like so how
does a leadership path look like well
let's say you are a senior Dev or a tech
lead or a solution architect and you can
basically go to becoming a engineering
manager so you might be wondering what's
the difference between a tech lead and
an engineering manager well or a staff
developer and engineering manager now
Tech lead and staff developer can be
completely different responsibilities
and roles and most likely they are but a
lot of companies also have them more or
less the same so let's talk about the
difference between a tech lead and an
engineering manager you can think of a
tech lead as a technical partner to an
engineering manager an engineering
manager is responsible for the
leadership of the team they are
responsible for making sure that they
are proper processes they're managing
the people people they are understanding
the organization strategy and making
sure that the technical strategy is also
intact but who is responsible for
executing it it's the tech lead a tech
lead is responsible for all the
technical aspect of things having said
that sometimes a tech lead is in fact
the engineering manager in specific
companies but a tech lead more or less
would be responsible for executing the
technical vision of the company and
making sure that the architecture is
intact and making sure that the
developers are following the best
practices they are participating in code
reviews and so on whereas the
engineering manager are more towards
process people technical Excellence
making sure the strategy is intact if
they do have any questions or if they do
have if they do want to implement
specific things and give feedback they
would necessarily work with the tech
lead and provide that feedback so that
they work well together and make sure
that the techn technical leader is
responsible for it but and ultimately
the leadership of the team is more on
the engineering manager versus the tech
lead because engineering manager is
responsible for management of people as
well Engineering Management role is more
of a leadership role whereas a tech lead
is less of a leadership role they are
still considered on the IC path and may
not be included in specific leadership
meetings because they are necessarily
more tied to the technical aspects of
things an engineering manager would be
going into those meetings understanding
the strategy giving feedback talking to
stakeholders and then partnering with
tech lead to give that information and
share that information with the team so
there's that barrier but sometimes
technical leads have that management
experience as well so they are also
invited to those specific meetings as
well Tech lead are also more Hands-On
compared to engineering manager and they
are responsible for the delivery of
specific features whereas engineering
managers on less hand on and depending
on the responsibilities and the scope of
the position they may not even code for
example because there is a tech lead
role but in a lot of companies there is
no Tech lead involved at all in that
case an engineering manager does play a
the tech lead role or they look for lead
developers within the team that are
interested in potentially becoming tech
leads and engineering manager works with
them to become technical leads and help
grow them and improve their technical
skills and Leadership skills because as
a tech lead you do need to have
leadership skills and that is why it can
be confusing because it is there is a
overlap of skills so what does growth
look like after you become an
engineering manager well you can become
a senior engineering manager and the
difference between the two is
engineering manager does lead a team of
developers but a senior engineering
manager leads a team of managers so they
have S several engineering managers
reporting under them I have been both an
engineering manager and a senior
engineering manager and I was working
towards being a director so a director
is more or less responsible for a
specific domain they are they look at
things more holistically beyond what a
senior engineering manager would do
they're responsible for a really big
domain and making sure the senior
engineering managers have what they need
and they are taking a look at things
even more holistically so it can happen
that being a director you are
responsible for a even bigger domain and
you have a lot more pressure and stress
because of it similarly senior director
is the same idea a few directors are
reporting into senior directors and same
thing for VP as well a VP overlooks the
entirety of engineering and they have a
bunch of directors and Senior directors
reporting into into the VP and the VP is
most likely reporting into the CT
and so on right but again like there are
so many different positions in Tech
especially on the leadership track that
you can go on to if you just want to
climb the ladder if you don't want to
that's completely okay if you decide
that hey I just want to be a engineering
manager I don't want to grow more I
don't want to take more responsibility
that's completely okay because you can
just focus on that specific position the
more you grow the more responsibilities
you are going to have as a developer so
you really need to assess where you see
yourself in 5 years or 10 years you may
not know now and that's completely okay
you can try a position and figure out if
you like it or not and that is why it is
my recommendation to all developers to
if there is an opportunity of a
leadership position within the team or
if there's an opportunity of getting
senen here even if you are on the IC
track take that position and first try
it out and see if you like it and if you
do like it then work with your manager
on potentially a promot motion path for
you because you have already proven
yourself for those skills so I really
hope this makes sense there is a website
called levels.fyi this is a really good
website to check what the different
levels are in every company what
salaries every position should have and
how it all works together because this
is extremely important for you before
you join a team or a company to look at
levels. fi and take a look at the
different positions and where you stand
as well I highly recommend you to reach
out to someone in the company and
understand what the different positions
are so that you know where you stand and
can apply for the position accordingly
now it can be very easy to say based on
all these titles that we looked at that
Tech lead is supposed to do this a staff
engineer is only supposed to do that or
an engineering manager is only tied to
maybe the people management
responsibilities but every company is so
different that you might see that
there's a lot of overlap and that is why
it could lead to a lot of confusion when
you're looking for a job as a leader or
as a developer in general so make sure
you take a look at the different
positions in the company and depending
on the scope of the orc like how big
your company is and the scope of the
work there's also a staff developer
involved and potentially a principal
developer that oversees even a bigger
domain or a specific domain so for
example example if let's say you want to
make sure that the notifications in your
company are properly taken care of there
should be some sort of notification
architecture that's there for maybe
mobile web and so on so how will the
architecture look like and in that case
maybe a technical lead maybe tied to a
small team will not be able to handle
that and might not have the domain
expertise and there needs to be someone
like a principal developer that looks at
add notifications for the entire company
and works with different teams
implementing those notifications so
maybe works with the mobile team working
for mobile notifications works with the
web team for web notifications and so on
so that from a user perspective those
notification are the same and users
don't need to know the technical
architecture and all the behind the
scenes of the code so again depending on
your company these roles can be very
different but it's important to know
which company you're going for so
accordingly you can go for the position
as well now here is my ask for you if
you join a company and if you notice
that there are no career ladders or
expectations are not clearly defined
please work with your manager please
work with your HR and give feedback to
them to make sure that these do get
implemented because without these it's
incredibly difficult for developers to
grow and otherwise one-on once with your
manager are just going to be things you
just talk about and there is no action
being implemented or if you do give this
feedback and if your manager says that
you need to work on X thing and if you
do work on it suddenly there's a y thing
that was never talked about that which
your prob which probably your manager
heard from some other manager who
probably has more influence in the
company so make sure that everything is
documented so that you know exactly what
it needs and what you need to get
promoted within the company now if
there's no career path or if there is no
documentation you can take the
initiative to Define it it doesn't
matter what level you are at in fact the
more initiative you take and the more
support you get this will start to get
more defined for all developers within
the company and having a process will
really help in this case so I really
urge you to create a process or create
something in your company if it doesn't
exist and try to get that alignment from
HR or your manager to begin with just to
get started I really hope this gives you
a solid understanding for what to look
out for when you're looking for a job
the different titles in the industry the
different career paths and so on so
let's take a look at this mind map that
I have created for us to walk you
through exactly what day in the life of
an engineering manager looks like you
don't necessarily need to do all of
these things in a day but these are some
things that you need to do and are
expected to do in your role as an
engineering manager so you can think of
this mind map as a checklist of things
that you should be doing so if you're
doing them great if you're not and if
you're curious about what it takes
become an engineering manager then this
is a great place for you so let's take a
look if you take a look at this mind map
there are several parts of this mind map
and I don't want you to be scared
because I have basically listed down all
the things that most engineering
managers are expected to do now keep
this in mind that every org and team are
quite different so you might be expected
to do more things or less things if they
already have a role for that if they
they already have a position for it
because Engineering Management and
project project management and a lot of
it it has a ton of overlap if there are
rules for that you might not necessarily
have to do those things but if not then
you might have to so I'm going to cover
a pretty robust road map but keep this
in mind so that you don't get scared
that you might have to do everything in
this this specific engineering manager
road map is divided into a few different
pillars one is organization team people
hiring product technical communication
and personal growth so let's take a look
at each one by one if you like a copy of
this mind map you can download it for
free take a look at the description
below if you like and you can have a
copy of your own so the first thing that
we are going to take a look at is
organization I would like you to have a
top- down view of your or so that you
are able to know exactly how your role
as an engineering manager plays in the
wi.org and how goals are set how you
create objectives for your teams and so
on start to zoom in on the or so there
are a few things you need to keep in
mind as we discuss about the orc
structure so the first is you need to
have a really solid understanding of the
vision of your orc and what the yearly
Vision looks like so every year maybe
towards the end of the year for the
upcoming year the founders or the senior
leaders meet and they discuss what the
vision for the orc should look like in
the next year or the next 5 years and so
on and accordingly they decide they want
to reach to X Milestone or X goals and X
number and that's how they decide okay
the yearly vision of this specific year
or the upcoming year is going to look
whatever now you need to understand that
Vision very clearly because then you are
going to make decisions for your team
based on that and you will understand
how your team plays a role in in that
Vision if you create goals for your
teams against those goals then I kind of
think of your team as a tiny boat which
is steering away which is going to
slowly turn the ship away because all
these tiny teams or all these tiny boats
for the ship are not heading in the
right direction so your ship is going to
slowly start turning away and that's not
what we want so have a good
understanding of the
or after you understand what the vision
of your org looks like try to understand
the business vision and the technical
Vision as well so based on the business
Vision the the VP the CTO or whoever
that might be or your senior leader
senior technical leaders are also going
to create a vision for your or so for
example we should move away from rest
apis and only use graphql or we should
make sure that all our experiences are
fully accessible and accessibility is a
priority for every user experience that
we create which it should be so whatever
that might be we are going to you need
to know that Vision so that you have a
better understanding for your team so
for example if accessibility is part of
it then you need to make sure that when
you are creating your road map for your
team accessibility is added as the
criteria because that's also part of the
vision the next thing is planning now
based on that vision and the goals of
your business you need to understand
which goals apply to you because there
might be goals for the entire company
based on those goals then you need to
start planning and planning your yearly
road map and then your quarterly road
map as well so based on that you're
going to assess you want to achieve x%
in in a year this is our goal and then
based on that for every quarter we are
going to try to meet X number right or
we are going to try to hit $10 million
or whatever that might be although how
many dollars does it associate to is not
necessarily in your control you also
partnering with product and design and
all the other departments as well
marketing and so on but you need to
assess what the quarterly goals look
like and then accordingly set ambitious
goals now one framework that you can use
to divide those big goals into smaller
goals is okrs okr stand for objective
key results and this is a framework
where you can assess how you can set a
ambitious objective associate that to a
key result you want to associate
yourself with um so I won't go too deep
into what okrs are but this should give
you a good understanding that it's a
framework that is quite commonly used
while planning for the year and for
while planning the road map the next
thing is collaboration with HR partner
so for your org whenever you have to you
also need to understand the decisions
that the org needs to make there's going
to be an HR in every HR department you
are going to have a partner that you
collaborate with and and that partner is
going to help you communicate exactly
what you what they need you to
communicate to their team so make sure
that you have a really strong
relationship with the HR partner and if
there is any downturn communication or
if there is any important or
communication or anything like that you
will be able to know exactly the words
to use to communicate that to your team
so that you make sure your team is in
the best spot possible and they have all
the information necessary as well so
again in organization these are a few
things you need to keep in mind the next
thing we're going to take a look at is
team now team is very important for you
as an engineering manager there are
quite a few things you need to do for
your team just to make sure that your
team is in the right spot and you have
full control as a leader now make sure
that you have good processes and there
is good documentation of processes
you're iterating on those processes as
well again too much process is not good
have a right balance for process
then task management such as who gets to
do who gets to work on what you need to
strike a really good balance here
because you don't want to get assign
tasks to folks that are not necessarily
interested in those tasks so make sure
you have a good understanding of the
people working on that tasks and and
also they are motivated to work on those
tasks as well and give them full
autonomy as well so for example some
people do create for autonomy so for
example if they do love autonomy then
assign them a task talk to them about
high level goals and let them have full
control in terms of how they want to
execute it and you can be the sounding
partner for them and understand how they
plan to implement it and so on but based
on what the interests are what the
strengths and weaknesses are accordingly
assigned tasks as well then you need to
also measure your team performance so
for team performance anything you want
to measure it needs to be track so that
you are able to measure so assign proper
metrics and track them conduct weekly
retrospectives retrospectives are a way
to reflect on how the week went what
went well what didn't go so well and so
on but this is how you can measure the
team performance for example if your
team's weekly output is a certain number
of tasks then make sure that you are
able to maintain that momentum if you
are not then your project planning might
not go as planned so make sure that you
have a good understanding of all of that
the next thing in Project management now
this is something that that you need to
understand that there might be another
role altogether in every company now
every compan is so different so if you
don't have this then you might have to
do it on your own or you have to gather
around the developers and assign these
roles and take turns doing them so for
project management you need to plan the
Milestones so for example what are some
tasks and Milestones you need to hit
along the way cu the project can be
maybe 4 to 6 months long or one to two
months long but what are the many
Milestones that you can hit on the way
just to Showcase to your stakeholders
and to your team and product managers
and everyone that you are heading in the
right path then you need to monitor that
performance you need to make sure that
you have good productivity practices if
you do know that there are certain
things that are maybe creating a lot
more toil for your team then maybe
invest some time into automating that
just because you don't want your team to
be wasting wasting time on things that
where they can be productive so make
sure that you do invest time there then
is prioritization grooming planning so
plan your tickets properly plan your
tasks properly make sure that the
backlog backlog of tickets is properly
groom and make sure that you understand
how to what the priorities are based on
the road map that you have planned as
well but again if the tick tasks have
proper detail then the developers would
be able to work on them as well but
obviously gather around the developers
and make sure you work on all of these
then is continuous Improvement any of
this will keep changing every month now
this is just a good list to have but you
need to make sure that you keep keep
improving you keep iterating with your
team now for every team different things
are going to work not everything is
going to work for every single team so
make sure you cater to that so one team
can differ from the other and so on a
very important pillar of Engineering
Management are the people so this is
something you need to handle in a very
delicate way cuz your decisions have a
huge impact on your team and people are
going to be impacted so make sure that
you know exactly what you're doing
always create a plan for it make sure
that your the decision makers with you
are also on the same page when you do
take a look at anything to deal with
people because you really want to make
sure you get this right so in people you
have to hire and onboard the people that
you work with now if you have a team of
maybe two Developers and if you want to
make a team if you want to create a team
of seven developers and five to seven is
usually the max for a team size uh or a
healthy Max for a team size for one
engineering manager and in that case you
need to make sure that you're hiring the
right people and onboarding them as well
and hiring and onboarding is a separate
pillar for this reason because there's
lots to talk about it so we will take a
look at it very soon next is the
happiness of the people it's very
important that you you Foster a culture
of transparency you create a
psychological safety for them and I I do
have a blog post written on this topic
if you're interested take a look in the
description but make sure that these
things do align with the team culture
and the people are happier in general
because this will add to the culture of
your team if people are happier people
are excited to wake up in the morning
and come work for you and you are going
to be more successful as a as a happy
outcome people are going to be more
productive because because of that cuz
they are interested in making the
company better so make sure that the
happiness is really accounted for the
next thing is feedback the way you
gather feedback and and the way you give
constructive feedback is extremely
important now feedback is so important
that you really need to make sure that
you build really good Frameworks and
patterns for people because different
people accept feedback differently
different people have require different
people ask for feedback in a very
different way so make sure that you
gather feedback about them in a proper
way and you also give them constructive
feedback as well then is career growth
now career growth is extremely important
in a developer life the developers
reporting into you really are interested
to know where they stand what can they
do to get to the next level and they
there should be full transparency
related to this so first are there any
career ladders set up in the company and
career ladders could be things like if
they are a intermediate developer then
maybe they want to get to senior
developer or staff developer principal
developer and so on now depending on the
level you're at there could be different
levels in every company so the career
ladder can be completely different in
every company now if they want to take
the individual contributor path then
they can or if they want to take maybe a
staff technical leader route then they
can do that as well now again depending
on the team that you work on for a staff
or a technical lead can be considered a
leadership position or it could be
considered an IC position and
engineering manager onwards is
considered a management position or
leadership position so again career
ladders differ from company to company
but make sure that you know what path
they want to go on so that you can give
them opportunities accordingly make sure
that every developer is creating smart
goals smart is a framework used to
create goals and I will link what smart
means in the description below but they
allow you to create really smart goals
then make sure that they do have a
development plan or a growth plan again
different companies call it different
things but a growth plan allows you to
document where they are at in their
Journey how their goals can tie to the
objectives that they working on and
those objectives align to the company's
vision and this is why I kind of give
you an idea of the or Vision the n road
map yearly vision and then these goals
should map to that so all the developers
are working to make the company better
then is the brag document a brag
document is a document where you
document exactly all the cool things
that you have done and things that you
are proud of so make sure every
developer in your team has a specific
back doog that they are proud of and
make sure there are also promotions
planned out and mapped out as well so if
they are already doing a good job at
meeting expectations or even exceeding
ceeding expectations in at a specific
level don't wait for them to ask you to
promote them when you think they are
ready start creating a plan with them
just to make sure that their career
growth is on track so again all of these
things are very important then is
performance reviews the performance
reviews are extremely important now one
thing you want to really avoid a m
mistake that you really want to avoid is
wait until the very last minute to give
a performance review to the person or to
give a feedback back to the specific
developer anything that comes out of
performance reviews none of it should
come as a surprise to the developer if
they are surprise you have not done a
good job as an engineering manager so
make sure that your performance reviews
are really on point and you already have
a document which is your growth plan
that ties it all together hiring the
right people in your team is going to be
majority of the battle for you if you
have really good people working for you
then it's going to be easier for you to
meet your goals your or goals and as a
result it's going to be really good for
your career growth as well so make sure
that you hire right if you don't hire
the right people it can have a serious
impact and that is why you need to make
sure you have good practices set up and
as well so let's talk about what happens
once once you hire so once you do hire
make sure you have really good
onboarding setup for them because your
goal as an engineering manager should be
that they do take the time to onboard
but it doesn't take too long for them to
onboard because you have set up the
right processes in place and everything
that they need to do and need to know to
get up and running quickly in their job
so make sure there's proper
documentation you have set up 30 60
90day goals for them so they have some
sort of a metric to hit so that they can
work on those goals in their 30 days in
their 60 days and in their 90 days so
make sure that first 90 days are set up
for success I have written a eBook on
your first 90 days as an engineering
leader and everything that you need to
do to make sure your first 90 days are
setup for Success if you're interested
take a look at the description below the
next thing you need to make sure you do
is go through diversity and unconscious
bias training as humans we all have our
own biases and we need to make sure when
we are hiring that those biases don't
interfere with the way we hire people
that's why it's important that you go
through this training before you start
interviewing people because then you're
going to know what are some of the
biases that you may have and how to make
sure that those don't play a role when
you're hiring folks make sure you
partner with recruiting as you're hiring
as well honestly recruiters are your
best friends during hiring if you tell
them what you're looking for they are
going to go and find people on LinkedIn
to make sure that the people are the
right fit for your specific team then is
interviews so when you're hiring make
sure you have really good process set up
to make uh to hire folks so make sure
there is diverse interview participation
there are people from your team
interviewing them as well so they are
comfortable for the new hires that are
going to join the team make sure that
there's a prop good technical challenge
setup and not something that anyone can
just Google then there's also a section
for soft skill assessment their
communication is on point so that you
know that they are a good fit for your
team conduct resume reviews and you also
hire for other teams as well so as much
as it's important that you hire for your
team you will also be expected to
interview other team members as well so
make sure that you're really a important
part of it that you're hiring for other
teams but you're also reviewing resumés
and making sure that you're making
you're improving the culture of the
company hiring is something that you do
need to invest really good time in
because as an engineering manager you
are going to hire folks for you not just
for your team team but also for others
team so understanding their goals and
hiring the right people will really help
you having a diverse set of interviewers
really make for a good interview
experience for the interview as well but
again hiring is going to be a really
important part of your role and
something you should not take it lightly
so far we have talked a lot about
different pillars of Engineering
Management but product is a pillar that
is extremely important as a engineering
manager
when you are making decisions as an
engineering manager you will also have a
product counterpart a design counterpart
and maybe several others too just to
make sure that all the decisions are
being made and all the key players are
in the room all those decisions are
being made for your team even though the
people in your team are reporting to you
there might be designers that are
reporting to a design manager or there
might be a product person that is
reporting to a to senior product manager
and so on so so you are you need to make
sure that you are not the only one
making decisions and having a really
tight collaboration with product I
should also add you your design is
extremely important or any other folks
that are important in decision making so
in product let's make sure that there is
business alignment so you understand
what the business is looking for and
when product does create a strategy as
an engineering manager you you review
that strategy and really are on the same
page as well you make sure you ideate on
different ideas that are really good for
the product create a different strategy
and collaborate on that strategy as well
and based on the product strategy make
sure you also have your technical road
map representation and focus as well so
if there's any technical that that needs
to be added or if there's any toil
that's being created for because of a
specific task on your team then make
sure that gets added and represented in
the technical road map as well a
technical road map is always a good idea
or features that you would like to
improve things that architecture that
needs to happen to make sure that we
sustain the scale of the product
requirements so again having a technical
road map would be really important and
something that you can initiate and get
the team involved to start creating next
is decision making and critical thinking
Al always as I mentioned earlier make
sure that all the key decision makers
are in the team and never say no make
sure that you use critical thinking just
to make sure that you don't just say no
but also are able to come up with
Creative Solutions for the problems
because again you need that creativity
to push the orc forward communicating
understanding of technical
requirements since you are a technical
person in the room you would have to a
lot of times communicate to product and
to other counterparts why certain tasks
are taking this long why something needs
to happen why the architecture needs to
be prioritized or whatever that might be
make sure that you're communicating that
and all of all of you are on the same
page and lastly prioritizing toil and
Technical debt in collaboration with
product as well so again if there's any
toil that's been created because of past
products or past features that you have
implemented or anything that just needs
to be prioritized then you need to
prioritize in the road map as well but
again get making sure everyone is on the
same page because you're not the only
Deion maker in the room so again
collaboration with product is extremely
important as a engineering manager we
should call this technical Excellence
because as an engineering manager you
need to make sure that your team is
following the best practices and
everything is under control from an
architecture perspective and so on as
well now again you don't need to solve
all these Pro all of these problems
yourself but get get the team together
to make sure that these problems are
being solved so for example in in in the
technical aspect there would be managing
on call and if there's any support
required and the off hour support
required then are there best practices
for it that you are monitoring toil so
you have proper dashboard set up just to
make sure everything is being tracked if
there are any incidents that have
created toil in the past and incident
could be some that let's say the system
goes down because of a feature that you
own or if there there was a mass impact
to the customers and make sure that you
have incident management practices as
well there's service ownership so
anything that you create you own so any
of the services that you own truly
belongs to you and your team and you
truly own that if if you have any
architectural best practices documented
as well so that anyone knew that any any
new team collaborating with your team
can refer that document just to make
sure everything is on point then there
is documentation and technical analysis
being done as well for every feature
that you work on so that anytime any new
feature needs to be worked on there's
documentation and there's a source of
Truth for everything so just make sure
that this is being done and again you
don't need to do it you can get your
team you can delegate these task to your
team to do it as well then there is
technical road map and alignment on
technical strategy which aligns with
what we talked about in product and then
there are good code quality processing
and templates created for your team
which allows your team to write better
code so for example there are better
code review practices there's a no blame
culture you are using pair programming
as a way to collaborate and get
developers together and improve their
skills and so on and lastly you have
proper practices for automatic deploys
which allows you to automate your entire
process in general so anything that can
be automated you can think of technical
bucket or technical pillar as a
technical Excellence bucket which allows
you to make sure that the technical
Excellence for your team is really great
and make sure that you are following all
the best practices possible while
deploying because otherwise you're just
going to create more toil which will
impact customers eventually so again
technical is really important
communication is a very important pillar
as a engineering manager you need to
make sure that you're communicating
right and effectively frequently with
your anyone who you're working with so
that you all are on the same page and
there are no misunderstandings in your
work culture so for example if you're
working cross team then there is coll
proper collaboration and practices with
cross teams that people are talking to
each other that there's proper meeting
facilitation the teams are working well
together make sure that you partner with
the engineering manager or the product
manager or the design manager or whoever
uh the whoever the leaders are of that
team so that you all are on the same
page and collaboration is is seamless
towards the end of the day all the team
members should be happy that the
collaboration happened so that it's
everyone is happier then if there there
are proper acing communication practices
after 2020 we are in a spot where a lot
of us are in the remote culture so it's
important that communication practices
are async and there are remote
communication practices and you don't
necessarily need to get in a call for
everything there are less meetings and
if there are meetings and a proper
agenda to those meetings there's proper
meeting facilitation as an engineering
manager a lot of times you might you
will find that you are facilitating
meetings and just asking questions and
asking the right questions to get the
conversation started so that the
decisions are being made not every
meeting will have the set of questions
necessary but just having the
communication there really helps a lot
and that you're are managing up as well
so you have a manager and you need
really need to make sure that whatever
you're working on you are also sharing
the work that you are doing and you're
truly owning up your career I have
written a blog post on managing up so
take a look at that because there's a
lot more to talk about while managing up
and why it's so important for your
career so make sure you're doing that
and communicating that because your boss
your manager is should be an ally for
you and they are going to be in rooms
that probably you're not going to be so
they need to represent your work and
that's why you make sure you communicate
effectively then there's stakeholders
now anytime you're working on something
there is a stakeholder for it there are
multiple stakeholders responsible for
the work that you're doing and they are
impacted their team is impacted with the
work you're doing as well so make sure
that there are frequent stakeholder
updates there's communication with
stakeholders they know how frequently
you are going to communicate and involve
them early so if your team was working
on something involve them early to get
their feedback because people people are
invested in the thing that they give
feedback on and that they put time and
in investment time investment in so if
they give feedback early they will be
more invested and as a result they are
going to be happier because they can see
that the team is already working on it
so this is why communication is
extremely important with stakeholders
and having a really good partnership
with them and as a manager communication
pillar is extremely important and if
there's one thing you need to start
doing as you transition from being a
developer to an engineering manager it's
communication make sure your
communication is on point we talked a
lot about communication with
stakeholders technical Excellence
product team growth people growth and
lots more but this is a very important
bucket as well I've mentioned this in
the past in other videos that
Engineering Management is just like
being on an airplane where you need to
put your oxygen Mass first and then give
the oxygen mask to your team so if you
don't if you cannot breathe you will not
be able to help your team either so make
sure you're investing time in your
personal growth as well you are leveling
up your skills and there are a few ways
you can level up your skills through
books and ebooks presentations to share
learnings book coffee chats with other
engineering leaders join communities
take courses and so on and as you
already know I'm already working on a
course on helping you become a
successful engineer manager if you're
interested add yourself to the weight
list and check out the course I'm really
excited for this course and everything
that I'm covering in this specific video
and lots more is also going to be
included and this is the part where you
really need to level up your skills and
make sure that the people on your team
don't become the experiment for your
growth so this course is really here to
help you for that so the next thing you
need to do for your personal growth is
also document your knowledge share your
learning with other leaders in the
company
make sure that you have a really good
relationship with them as well because
who knows when your team would need to
work with them but also it's important
that having a good Network around you
would really help you grow in your
career as well then setup goals for
yourself again uh everything that we
talked about in the growth section for
your team also applies to you as well
make sure that you do have a development
plan that you're working on you are
setting up smart goals as well you are
creating those goals and measuring as
well because again as I said before
because as an engineering manager it's
extremely important that you measure
everything so make sure that you are
doing that for yourself as much as you
doing that for your team as well and
about all of this it's important that
you take care of your mental health and
personal development as much as you care
for your team I really hope you have a
solid understanding for what it's like
to become an engineering manager and how
that first from being a developer just
by comparing the day in the life of an
engineering manager we got to know a lot
about what a developer does and doesn't
do and what an engineering manager does
behind the scenes you can read all the
books in the world take unlimited
workshops on how to become a leader but
unless you get practical experience you
are never going to know what leadership
looks like so in this specific video we
are going to talk about how you can find
opportun unities as a leader what does a
good leader even mean or what do they do
what are some things you should avoid
doing as a leader my name is anira and I
am an educator and I will help you level
up in your engineering career I have
more than a decade worth of experience
leading developers so you are in good
hands let's get started so the first
thing you should do if you haven't
already is become a mentor for someone
we all have something that we can teach
teach others based on our experience so
figure out how you can become a mentor
in the company that you work at or even
in general figure out who asks you a
bunch of questions and see if they're
interested in potentially being your
mentee because being a mentor would be a
really good valuable experience for you
to start tapping into leadership it is
kind of like the beginner phase of
leadership you will sort of understand
what it's like to grow someone else
you're not directly responsible for
their career or their growth right now
but you still invested in them so you
will kind of get an idea what it's like
to become a leader next you should
figure out if there is a small project
that you can lead so again you can
figure out how to work with people how
to assign them tasks how to figure out
what the priorities are and also work
with your direct manager as you are in
this lead capacity so you will also
start to see what your manager does in
certain situations being a lead so so
figure out and identify small projects
that you can work on as a leader start
shadowing your manager in meetings
figure out what decisions they make see
what the day in the life of your manager
looks like because that's potentially
also going to be your day as well if you
Shadow your manager you can start taking
on leadership responsibilities but also
figure out if this is something that you
like or not cuz if you don't like it you
don't want to do it that's completely
okay but at least by this you would be
able to figure out what even a good
leader does you become the average of
Five People You surround yourself with
if your goal is to become a leader or
figure out how to become a leader what
you can start doing is find out who in
the company is a leader you aspire to
become you will learn a lot by watching
them and also context is very important
so you will figure out what engineering
leadership looks like in the company
that you work at so find a mentor that
can help you get there discuss them your
potential goals and your interests and
that you're trying to figure out if you
want to become a leader or not a leader
in one company might struggle in another
that's why finding a mentor in your orc
would really help you speed up that
learning process so what makes a good
leader if you want to become one you
need to figure out what is a secret
source to becoming a leader now there's
never a checklist of things that I can
provide and say that yeah check this off
and you will become a good leader
leadership is complex because we deal
with people and people are humans so you
need to tweak your checklist and add to
it or remove items from it depending on
the orc you work at but here are a few
things that makes a good leader you will
notice that the people that work for the
that leader are incredibly happy or even
if they are not very happy they are
satisfied with their job and job
responsibilities a good leader will
always know how to build a high
performing team and a high performing
team is not a team of high performers a
high performing team is essentially a
team that collaborates effectively knows
how to give feedback to each other they
ship fast they iterate and they move on
a good leader will know how to create a
high performing team out of any
situation a good leader is not just
growing the people on their team but
they are also driving business results
which are very very important you can
think of this analogy where you can
imagine a duck swimming in a pond when
you look look at that duck the duck
seems really calm and everything is
going okay but underwater you will
notice that the duck is working really
hard to make sure that they seem calm on
the surface level and that's exactly
what a good leader would look like you
will not notice that there's a lot of
work that's going on in the background
because they're doing such a good job
shielding the team from all the chaos
and pressure that's happening in the or
so good leader will definitely Ely be
doing that a good leader will know
exactly how to grow people at different
skill levels and if they don't know then
they're going to ask others for help and
figure out how you can grow in your team
they are never going to give you the
answers they're always going to coach
you and question you so that you can
come to those answers yourself and it it
always creates that light bulb moment
for you a good leader will not give you
the answers cuz they know that in the
future you're going to come back to them
with the same question but if they ask
you then you will come to that answer
yourself and you don't need to ask them
in the future and that's what a good
leader does communication is extremely
important as a leader and a good leader
will always communicate effectively
thoughtfully and will prepare their
communication before any major event so
for example there might be different
types of communication there could be
one-on-one communication with the direct
reports or people they work with or they
could be orgb communication or big ch
Channel communication and a good leader
will always thoughtfully prepare what
communication looks like because
communication can literally make or
break a company it can create chaos and
it will create uncertainty and you don't
really want that so if you want to be a
good leader you need to make sure that
you're communicating thoughtfully and
effectively a good strategy for this is
always create a document and write down
everything that you want to say and
review it and tweak it and use your
words wisely and and then get other
leaders to review the document as well
before sharing it in a channel because
the impact of that could be huge and
this way you are aligned on the
communication so a good leader will
always have really good communication
strategies I have a video coming out on
how to effectively communicate that you
should check out a good leader will
always create psychological safety now
psychological safety means that you can
make mistakes as a developer or as a
member of the team and you you won't be
punished for it there are no bad
consequences for it as a developer you
are going to make a lot of mistakes so
imagine if your manager or your leader
doesn't create a psychologically safe
place to make mistakes then you are
going to have a ton of bugs and you are
always going to hide your mistakes and
if you want to be a good leader you
should never do that so a good leader
will always create a psychologically
safe place for you to make mistakes and
and won't punish you for it instead
figure out a way to avoid those same
mistakes in the future and create a
process for it as a good leader you must
always praise publicly and give feedback
privately so this is a perfect example
wherein if you want to create a
psychologically safe place never bash
anyone publicly cuz you're going to
create that fear for everyone else on
your team and you really don't want to
do that a good leader will create that
safe space for everyone to make mistakes
as a good leader you always want your
people to grow and level up if they are
stagnated if they're not growing then
what's the point you need to make sure
that the people on your team are growing
and this will really make you a good
leader because you are helping them grow
you're giving them feedback you are
creating a development plan for them
you're really figuring out the gaps they
have and helping them get to the goal
that where they want to get to or you
helping them love V up so really you
need to make sure that the people on
your team are growing as a really good
leader you don't need to problem solve
each and everything as you did as a
developer now you need to handle
problems on a Case by casee basis
because these problems are often
problems with people so a good leader
will know exactly how to handle a
specific difficult situation you never
want to run away from difficult
situations as a leader and you should
almost be comfortable dealing with it
and it can be hard at first but the more
you do it the better it get but Handle
With Care and handle with thoughtfulness
and it will always come across as
genuine so as a leader you always want
to analyze things on a casee by case
basis and figure out problems or
brainstorm problems together you might
have a lot of control as a leader and a
lot of power as a leader but you still
want people to come work for you and if
you act like a boss and not as a leader
then
you will not have those people coming to
work for you and you really don't want
to do that because you will not have a
team so really make sure that you don't
act like a boss but you start being a
leader start acting like a leader and
based on some of the things I talked
about because if you start being a boss
then you're commanding and people don't
like to work for bosses so start being a
good leader you need to lead by example
as a leader you need to have a positive
influence on others
by growing other people you are going to
grow yourself as well and you're going
to level up your skills as well now if
you want people to follow you and if you
really need to walk the talk if you want
people to follow the same guidelines and
rules that you have set for them so for
example if you don't want people to work
late then don't work late as well if you
don't want people to DM each other or
message in Channel
after work hours then don't message in
work channels or be online or show them
that you are online after work because
again people are just going to follow
you because you're the leader so whether
you like it or not the behaviors that
you adopt as a leader are something that
is going to be easily trickered down to
all your to all your team members
because as a lead you're setting the
culture of your team so really need to
make sure that you're leading by example
when people say that they love or hate
the company they work for you can be 90%
confident that they're talking about
their manager because a manager can
really make or break someone's career so
you really need to make sure that you
are being a good leader and setting a
good example for them I have mentioned a
million different things for what makes
a good leader and I can say a million
more things more but again as I
mentioned at the beginning of this video
you really need to make sure that you
you are gaining that practical
experience finding that those
opportunities for yourself in order to
hopefully become a leader in the future
hard skills get you hired but soft
skills get you promoted if you had to
pick one soft skill that you truly need
to master that it has to be
communication after leading 100 plus
developers and leaders I can assure you
that folks that knew how to communicate
grew quickly got promoted and truly
created that impact that lasted for
years if you are interested in leveling
up and getting promoted then keep
watching in this video I'm going to
share a four-step simple formula for you
to create a communication strategy that
you can apply in any type of meeting so
let's get started so the first step in
this formula is identify who you're
communicating with knowing who you're
going to communicate with is going to be
a GameChanger for you you know why
because after you know who they are you
can share more or less context in that
meeting before you get into that meeting
figure out who's going to attend the
meeting what their roles are what do
they care about what their objectives
are and how do they tie into the context
of the meeting and why were they invited
to begin with knowing that is going to
be huge for you because then you can
accordingly decide whether you should
provide more context whether you should
ask them more questions or how they're
going to help your team this is going to
make you look more confident because you
are because you have prepped for that me
meeting so identifying who you're going
to communicate with is going to be a
game Cher unfortunately 90% of the folks
don't know which meeting they're getting
into they wait for the calendar to to
notify them five minutes before the
meeting and then they decide to go into
that meeting not knowing the purpose of
the meeting who's attending the meeting
and then that completely slows down the
meeting so in order to craft a really
good communication strategy you need to
do the opposite of that you need to
identify y who you're talking to so you
know how to best position
yourself the second part of the formula
is to focus on the outcome that you
would like to get to now hold on a
second and take a let's take a step back
here focusing on the outcome is so
important if you know what you want to
get out of that meeting before you even
get into it or if you want to what you
want to get out of that discussion then
you can basically backtrack and figure
out exactly
what questions you want to ask and how
you want to position that meeting a lot
of times we get too invested in the
solutions or we are too passionate about
the problem that we figure out what
exactly we want to get out of the
discussion with anyone so if you figure
out what exact outcome you want to get
to then you can backtrack and craft
steps for how you want to get to that
outcome if you get into the meeting and
you realize that this meeting is not
productive and you will not get closer
to the outcome in fact you are getting
derailed by completely different
conversation then backtrack and figure
out what your outcome is and remind your
team of that outcome so for example if
you get into a heated discussion on
architectural decision with another
teammate instead of getting too heated
up try to figure out what is the outcome
you would like to get to based on your
discussion now the outcome is that you
need to agree upon a common solution
that works for your team and for the
business business and for your company
right that is the outcome then you
shouldn't get too hung up on having
opinions that are not supporting that
specific outcome so again if you do that
and backtrack it that will really help
you understand where you would like to
get to now whatever strategy that we are
discussing right now the four step
formula along with examples if you like
a template for it then take a look in
the description below and download the
template for
free
now the third part of the formula is
what impact you would like to create
from the specific meeting now in order
to make sure that you're creating impact
as part of every meeting you need to
create a well structured meeting so for
example before you even get to the
meeting make sure that every meeting has
a clear agenda and whatever outcome that
we have just talked about is also
documented in that specific meeting so
people are aware what to discuss upon if
the meeting gets derail make sure that
people discuss the main topic of that
specific meeting and discussion engage
participants in the meeting so for
example you know that you need
marketing's input or if you need a
specific developers input in that
meeting make sure that you get ask their
input and make it a engaging meeting so
that it's not just you who's making the
decision but it's the entire team or the
entire group that's invited to the
meeting really thinking out loud and
giving their opinion because again
in order to make sure that you level up
and get promoted and really come across
as a confident Communicator you really
don't want to do this on your own you
really want to bring the entire group
together to do do this together and
manage time effectively time is very
important if you make sure that the
meeting starts on time and ends on time
that is going to be really really
important for everyone because again
time is energy the more time you spend
on something the more energy you're
going to spend on something so you
really don't want to make sure that you
are are managing the meeting right and
making sure that starts on time and ends
on
time if you are getting into a meeting
or a discussion you need to think about
what should people remember about you as
they walk away from that meeting so for
example if you are really trying to
create a brand around graphql and you
really want people to remember that you
are a graphql expert or you really know
a lot about graphql then before you get
into that meeting prep for that meeting
and really note down what are the
different typ typ of questions that are
going to be asked as part of that
discussion and answer them and help the
team even if you don't know the answer
that's completely okay you can take away
those questions and really figure out
how to help the team later on but again
make sure that you know what impact you
would like to create as part of that
meeting the minute you start thinking
about that you're going to behave a bit
differently than you do you're going to
start being more active in the meeting
you're going to be an important part of
the meeting which is really really
important if you are interested in
knowing how to be a great leader and in
fact how to be a badass one then check
out another video that I have
created the fourth step in the formula
is what are some of the actions that you
can create as part of this specific
discussion where the end of every
meeting or towards the end of every
discussion there are a list of action
items that you can take away that you
can work on you can remind the group of
that you can remind the team of that but
you can also take away some of those
action items and make sure that they are
delivered once they are done let the
team know in the channels that you're
part of where all your other team
members are because again that's going
to make you look a lot more confident
and you are communicating seamlessly
what action items can you take from that
specific discussion or meeting make sure
that it's documented somewhere so that
everyone knows what you have discussed
there's no room for miscommunication and
misunderstanding because everything is
documented make sure that you get
alignment from everyone else by
repeating the goal of the meeting and
the action items that came out of that
meeting because you are going to look
more confident and prepared and you know
exactly everyone is aligned on that
specific topic and overall just be
helpful in making sure that discussion
gets to the specific outcome that you
would like to get to the key thing here
is that throughout this specific video
and in this specific formula I have
talked about all the different ways you
can communicate how you need to be
prepared for the meeting how you need to
make sure that you're answering
questions how you can share context and
so on and all of these things if you
keep repeating over and over you are
going to come across as really confident
because you're someone who is prepared
for the meeting you know exactly what
the discussion is about so you know that
you have that additional leverage over
others in that specific meeting this
lesson we are going to talk about some
Frameworks that we can use to learn how
to give feedback effectively and the
importance of feedback
overall now feedback is so personal and
unique that you would need to keep
evolving your framework you will learn
that the feedback you may give to one
person is completely different to the
feedback you share with someone else so
feedback is so personal and so unique
that you need to keep evolving
it and we have talked about the Buddy
pattern in the anti patterns lesson and
you want to be liked and loved so badly
that you you will never give a single
piece of negative feedback and we talked
about this as the bud pattern in the
Andy patterns lesson of engineering
leadership you want to be like we want
to be loved because we are humans after
all and we never want to do the hard
things of giving feedback but this
behavior is not going to create any
positive team culture in fact it's going
to do the opposite of that you're going
to slow down your learning you're going
to slow down your team because you're in
danger because this might might lead to
more potential Behavior which might be
worse for your team you really need to
make sure that you give feedback and
feedback is the best gift you can give
it to someone most leaders are scared to
give feedback because they might they
think that their colleague might not
take it take them in the right way the
colleague might get defensive get mad at
you for sharing feedback but it is the
best give you can give it to
someone negative feedback is difficult
you may find excuses to not do it or
postpone it but keep this in mind that
if you're not sharing this feedback you
will you give them zero chance of
improvement and that is not fair to them
so giving negative feedback is extremely
important and the problem is never the
person themselves it's the behavior that
they're exhibiting and if you know this
about feedback that it's not the person
it's not personal it's the behavior that
we need to rectify suddenly a lot of
things change when you're you're giving
feedback and if we want to and if we
combine that with our initial fight or
flight response then it gets worse
you're likely to experience a social
threat when facing people of higher
status feeling or sense of uncertainty
or feeling disconnected which is
something that is unfair now if you
combine that with like fire or flight
response it's no wonder feedback is not
part of our high priority list because
whenever we receive feedback we get
really defensive and that's not what we
want but that's what happens and that's
why feedback is difficult to receive and
to
give but one hot tip is that you don't
give feedback or take any action that
will impact others if you don't have the
time to address the feedback or if you
don't have time to listen to their story
that is if you're in a rush because if
you're in a rush to give someone to
feedback it's a sign that you have
failed them before you even got started
with them it's best to hold off until
you have something concrete or or
positive to say and have more something
constructive to say because when you're
feeling like you have to give someone
feedback and you cannot wait until
tomorrow it's a sign that maybe you
there's a problem with you you are
insecure or something that has gone
wrong with you or they had a really
massive impact on you with the behavior
that they exhibited so make sure that
you take the time take the day off don't
stress too much and after you give it
some time collect your thoughts and give
them
feedback and reflect when you felt
grateful after receiving feedback so
think of a time when someone gave you
feedback that actually made you feel
good even though it was constructive
feedback how did they convey their
message how did why did you value that
feedback how did that make you feel
think of that as you start to craft and
learn to give feedback more frequently
to your team and we have a framework
this is one of my favorite Frameworks to
use which is SBI framework with the
twist now we can divide this framework
into three parts Parts situation
Behavior impact and outcomes Now
situation as in what was the situation
that happened where you felt the need to
give feedback what was the situation
like were you in meetings did someone
say something what was the situation
what is the
behavior that you would like to change
what Behavior impacted the team or
impacted you or someone else on your
team you want to be very careful of that
for example if they're interrupting in
meetings then you need them not to do
that so let them know the behavior needs
to change where they they need to stop
interrupting others and you know make
others feels feel excluded and impact is
that your other team members felt
excluded and that is the impact from
their behavior right and the situation
was that you were in a team meeting
discussing ideas and thoughts and
someone came off really strongly and
kept interrupting everyone else in the
meeting that's not how you want right
and that's the essence of SBI framework
but I like to add a Twist and say let's
also focus on the outcome because then
that helps you with feedback in general
what is the outcome you would like from
that conversation when you're giving
feedback is the outcome that you would
want their behavior to change you don't
want them to interrupt others in the
meeting then let them know that so the
outcome here is not just you and me
right let's try to figure out what is
that behavior that we need to change
because it's not them it's the behavior
right and you can also use this
infographic here to use SBI framework
with the twist so that you can easily
reference it in the future when you're
giving
feedback so let's say you have a
situation let's take a look at an
example you have a team member that is
very senior in the orc and is not
mentoring Junior devs and not really
prioritizing them what is something that
you need to do well your first instinct
is going to be that this is not okay
this in this case would be that you
would want this Behavior to stop or
change and that's going to be your first
instinct but the second is going to be
that they're mean and they're rude that
they're constantly talking over people
this is not making the team feel good
and the team is not speaking up because
of that and that is the
impact so let's try giving this feedback
using this framework and these are the
list of questions that I have in the
workbook that you can use to craft this
specific feedback that is what is the
outcome what is the context what is the
situation what Behavior needs to change
why do you think this happened and what
was the impact that it had on the team
you can use these questions to craft a
really good feedback message so workbook
time you want to collectively craft a
feedback message using a SBI model with
a Twist and make sure that you uh give
it a shot so what are some important
things to note about feedback right you
always want to be open to hearing their
side of the story their feedback right
because as much as you are open to
sharing yours they also have a side to
it which is very important so maybe you
don't have contexts to new things that
could have happened that maybe they did
not let anyone else talk because you
were in a client meeting and the you
knew a backstory with sign which would
significantly impact the
project it there could be many different
reasons and then suddenly you start
feeling like oh that's why they kept
interrupting others
and even though that's not okay and they
should never do that there's a better
way to handle it and their feedback can
change based on that and lastly document
the action items what are the takeaways
for them and ask them what the action
items were from this so that you make
you can make sure that there's alignment
the answers should always align to what
you talked about but and it shouldn't be
perfect but it should have the essence
of what you are looking for there this
is an thank you so much for checking out
this course on engineering leadership I
really hope you like it if you do and if
you have any questions please let me
know in the comments below but if you
want to continue learning further and if
you're serious or even curious about
becoming an engineering leader or a
manager then you can also check out this
course that have created called as
developer to leader it will take you
from being a developer wherever you are
at to becoming a successful engineering
leader and it will teach you how to lead
a team how to grow a team how to hire
right how to create a engineering Vision
how to create a technical road map and
how to deliver feedback how to receive
feedback and lots more that I couldn't
necessarily cover in this specific
course so I really hope you check it out
and if you do then you can use the code
free Cod cam for 25% off additionally as
well so I really hope you check it out
and once again thank you so much for
watching and I hope you have a wonderful
day bye for now